[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the wonderful things that that I
have and that was given to me was by the
Wachowskis we filmed in Sydney Australia
and when I arrived at where I was going
to stay was a black box on the table and
inside the black box
was a red pill and that is fantastic
[Music]
now remember us growing up there was
this Michael Apted documentary called
7up which really struck me I'd never
seen that or you know as a young person
then there was like the thin blue line
Errol Morris that was well you know and
then and what we do to documentary
hearts of darkness you know behind
Apocalypse Now also visions of light and
then and then one that was done the
century of the self by Adam Curtis at
BBC that was pretty remarkable that was
like yeah and then there was a 911
documentary called 911 mysteries
demolition that was pretty powerful and
Bowling for Columbine and what has so
those are some of the big ones
[Music]
nowadays I think it's always do you
respond to the story you know when you
read a script do you respond to the
story and then looking at the role that
you're going to play in that story or
hope to play and after that who are you
working with who's the director who's
producing who what is the environment
for it but it starts with the story and
then the character happiness is I guess
I can only do like a kind of emotive run
on that which is like it's all good
everything's good you're feeling good
you're doing something that makes you
feel good you're working with people
loving with people yeah just it's all
good
you